foreign
[Music]
fellow Cosmic explorers to the cosmic
Chronicles podcast where imagination
meets reality and science fiction comes
to life I'm your host Quinn and I'm once
again joined by my co-host James what's
going on James hey what's up if you
would like to sponsor this podcast you
can email us at cosmicchroniclespodcast
gmail.com you can also find our podcast
on Spotify Apple podcast Amazon music
Google podcast or wherever you listen to
podcast and be sure to subscribe to our
YouTube channel as well
[Music]
our topic today is lovecraft's at the
mountains of Madness and Ridley Scott's
Prometheus we are both big fans of both
works and there are a lot of
similarities between the two of them in
this episode we discuss both lovecraft's
short story and Ridley Scott's epic
science fiction movie and compare them
to each other
so let's start with the author himself
who is H.P Lovecraft
so HP Lovecraft was a writer from the
1920s
kind of a bizarre figure kind of a
bizarre man he had a lot of personal
flaws but those personal flaws allowed
him to write really terrifying stories
and stories that were rooted in real
fears that he himself possessed so
Lovecraft mainly wrote horror Thriller
mystery stories but he is credited with
inventing or at least popularizing the
genre of cosmic horror what we call
today sometimes lovecrafty and horror
and it is horror that is focused on
things of an existential nature things
Beyond human perception you know deep
Horrors deep fears um hidden beyond the
stars hidden beneath the uh ocean uh the
fears of things that are far beyond our
control things that are at a scale and
at a level of complexity e or at a level
of intelligence that compared to humans
and anything that we can do is um is
kind of mind-blowing to us so Lovecraft
is known for popularizing or inventing
Cosmic horror
and as I said he had a lot of personal
flaws one of the main ones was that he
was very xenophobic
um he feared really anything that he
didn't have a lot of knowledge on he
feared the unknown and that is what
really manifest in his stories so much
of the root fears in his stories is
based on the fear of the unknown so I
think that lovecraft's kind of inherits
strangeness as a human being definitely
contributes to the way his stories feel
and he's obviously been very very very
influential in the horror genre and the
science fiction genre since then
although he was not famous successful or
popular at the time of his life he was
never rich off of his Works he never was
well known he only came to popularity
posthumously and also recently I would
say in the last 20 years or so Lovecraft
has had a significant Resurgence so what
are some of the main themes of
lovecraft's work the main themes of
lovecraft's work include things like
isolation like I said the fear of the
unknown uh Cosmic dread uh secret
forgotten history of the world the idea
that there are these evil entities
malevolent forces beyond our
comprehension the idea of Forgotten uh
tainted abnormal ancestry
um Lovecraft dealt with fears and themes
related to just the existential nature
of existence and these are themes that
manifest in basically all of his stories
in some shape or form so let's get into
the short story at the mountains of
Madness what is it about so as I said at
the mountains of Madness is one of my
all-time favorite Lovecraft short
stories and one of yours as well yeah at
the mountains of mad this is about an
expedition to Antarctica by some
scientists and explorers and about what
they find there and what they uncover
about the secret slash forgotten history
of the earth and the beings that used to
rule over the Earth and this unfolds in
a very like
slow but very compelling way that like
drives you along in the story as you're
delivered bits and pieces of information
as The Story Goes On before we reach a
huge Crescendo at the end where we have
this huge info drop and it's just a very
very satisfying story you feel like
you're on this Expedition with them as
they uncover these Mysteries so that is
a basic idea of what the story is about
without giving away too much initially
the mountains of Madness specifically
refers to this mysterious
quote-unquote mountain range that they
uncover in Antarctica that shouldn't
exist it's taller than Everest and it's
just very very strange and there's an
epic quote from when they first uncover
it that I really like a lot
in the whole spectacle there was a
persistent pervasive hint of stupendous
secrecy and potential Revelation as if
these Stark nightmare spiers Mark the
pylons of a frightful Gateway into
forbidden spheres of dream and complex
Gulfs of remote time space and Ultra
dimensionality I could not help feeling
that they were evil things mountains of
Madness whose further slopes looked out
over some accurset ultimate Abyss
so I feel like this quote really evokes
the terror and the Mystery of the
mountains and it really represents the
fact that in this scene we are passing
over into a new realm the realm of the
old ones we are moving beyond the
Dominion of men and into the Dominion of
something that's much more ancient and
mysterious and Powerful so Lovecraft is
often associated with horror but his
Lovecraft science fiction
I think that Lovecraft can be science
fiction at the mountains of Madness
certainly is science fiction the Dunwich
Horror not so much so I think that
Lovecraft has Supernatural elements in
his stories and then he also has science
fiction elements and his stories and
then also sometimes he Blends them
together
um and it's that age-old saying
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic and a lot
of times when Lovecraft is talking about
certain things they're described in a
magical sense and he's talking about
things like spells and incantations and
demons and things but we also have to
remember that these things are being
relayed through the lens of human beings
who see certain things a certain way we
can't actually comprehend
these beings and and even their
languages and the way they communicate
so in this story they find something
hidden in Antarctica what is it that
they find well the specific the main
thing that they find hidden is an
ancient
City a huge ancient city in Antarctica
that should not exist it predates all
human cities it predates civilization it
is ancient beyond belief and they also
find
bodies uh what seem to be animal bodies
they think at first but there's
something very bizarre about them they
are no species unlike any species that
has ever been uncovered or seen on Earth
before and within this huge cyclopean
City they find also hieroglyphs that
detail this ancient forgotten history of
the world that does not concern Humanity
so where did the beings who built the
city come from and how did they get here
so this is a very interesting question
so we learn in the short story that
these beings were called The Elder
things and the Elder things are in fact
some of the bodies that the scientists
uncover and start to dissect and the
Elder things like all of the old ones
that once inhabited the Earth came from
beyond the stars
um these were I guess
human like beings in the sense that they
were intelligent and that they built
cities and that they had technology but
they reached an apex of technology that
surpassed us even at our greatest level
um as I said they had the ability to
move through the stars now exactly how
they moved to the stars and exactly how
they got here is a little bit ambiguous
um and we kind of have to take pieces
from all sorts of Lovecraft stories and
piece it together to try and understand
how the Elder things and the other old
ones moved around and Carla Cthulhu it
very specifically says that it was
heavily tied to the alignment of planets
in this book it says that somehow the
Elder things were able to Traverse the
interstellar either through use of their
wings
um but I don't think that Lovecraft
literally meant they were flying through
outer space with Batman
like if I had to guess it has something
to do with kind of like I don't know
maybe they produced a rift in space-time
or somehow a Gateway was opened up a
portal was opened up and this would kind
of explain I think why the Call of
Cthulhu mentions that their ability to
move was tied to the alignment of stars
it's kind of like they had like a
Interstellar roadway system or something
like that just a speculation because
it's like I said it's kept pretty vague
in this story and throughout the entire
Mythos of Lovecraft how exactly they
came to Earth but we know they came from
distant regions in outer space or
perhaps even more distant perhaps even
from other dimensions or other region or
other Realms of existence can you
speculate on why they came to Earth
well that's an interesting question
because I don't know if this is
something that's ever really touched on
or specifically hinted at but if I had
to guess if I had to get into like a
really uh speculative territory we know
that the great old ones their language
was the language of thought they
communicated with thought so perhaps
there was something cosmically special
about the Earth because we know they
fought over the Earth among themselves
even
um so perhaps the Earth was I don't know
a Nexus of psionic energy a Nexus of
thought cosmic energy for whatever
reason and that was the the specific
reason we know that Cthulhu is called
something like the great sorcerer or
great priest he was casting
quote-unquote spells on the universe and
causing some kind of change to occur and
um perhaps the alignment in the position
the specific place and the cosmos was
important for whatever reason obviously
there was something about the Earth that
Drew them here as to what exactly that
is I think will always be left for
interpretation and speculation so you
mentioned they had to battle for the
Earth and one of the things that they
battle in the book is Cthulhu how are
these Elder things related to Cthulhu
and the great old ones
so it's loose because in the mountains
of Madness the Elder things are also
sometimes referred to as the old ones
but then in the Call of Cthulhu and
other things they talk about the great
old ones so perhaps they were like of a
similar class of being but I feel like
it's heavily implied that Cthulhu is
like the big bad amongst them Cthulhu is
very very powerful
um he's a great Magician of the Universe
um and it does mention in the mountains
of Madness that the Elder things went up
against the pre-human spawn of Cthulhu
and they battled for Dominion of the
Earth the exact relationship is unknown
these could just be like totally
unrelated like groups of beings that
just happen to be coming for the Earth
at the same time or they could have I
guess deeper history within the cosmos
within the macroverse
um it's it's a pretty it's it's
something that's pretty much left for
speculation I think there's not a lot of
concrete information about how all the
old ones relate to each other
within lovecraft's actual original
Mythos now I know various authors later
on have written things in Lovecraft
Smith those that has gone on to connect
the old ones to each other and even
invent new old ones
um you know parent figures to creatures
like Cthulhu and azathoth and stuff like
that but as far as lovecraft's actual
intention I think that the vagueness of
it relates to the fact that everything
that we know about this history comes
from you know translations of
translations and people that kind of
understand what they're reading but it's
also written in languages that were
never meant for human comprehension and
they're all like pieced together from
scraps and bits of information so there
are some contradictions in our things
that we'll never that are just like
holes in the data um as there were as
there is just like in actual history so
what kind of Technology apology did the
Elder things possess that's an
interesting question the mountains of
Madness definitely mentions that they
had energy weapons that worked by means
that we don't understand so they were in
in the great Wars between the Elder
things and the spawn of Cthulhu they
fought with these energy weapons and
they also had the ability to Traverse
the stars and it the way that operated
almost seems like magic but it was
definitely like some form of Technology
if you really think about it
um and they had other form means of
Technology like means of you know
building actual cities in ways that like
we don't understand how they like if you
look at the way
the way the construction of things like
relay is described or the way the
construction of the city
um in in the mountains of Madness is
described this is these are not human
building methods so they obviously had
some form of technology that was very
very very very Advanced and it does
mention that their technology was far
more advanced than anything that
Humanity had reached at least by the
time of Lovecraft and and probably by
now as well there's an interesting part
where the narrator suggests that if they
had different senses that it might have
changed the way the art is experienced
he says that certain touches here and
there gave vague hints of symbols and
stimuli which another mental or
emotional background in a fuller or
different sensory equipment might have
made a profound significance to us so
that's tied back kind of to their
incomprehensible nature and kind of how
advanced their technology was you know
they were human-like in a lot of ways
like they wore armor
um they were farmers they had
agriculture they had sufficiently
Advanced you know like bioengineering
you know biological technology you know
they they Farm what the book called
saurians which yeah it suggests they
might have had dinosaur Farms perhaps
dinosaur Farms they were around when the
dinosaurs were before the dinosaurs long
before the dinosaurs even came around so
it and and also there were things like
the Chagas also so that hint at their
biological engineering prowess as well
so they had very very very advanced
technology a lot of it that's
incomprehensible to us it's almost like
their technology
is also art in some cases perhaps if we
did have you know a higher degree of
Senses there there would be more like
even more details hidden within it I
kind of It kind of reminds me of like it
kind of makes me think of how like you
you're like a computer chip or something
how we can store data on a computer chip
but A Primitive person can't read that
data without you know the proper sensory
equipment you need a computer to hook
the data into to read
um
and also it kind of reminds me of a
quote from Dune as well uh what senses
do we lack that we cannot see and hear a
hidden world all around us
um so yeah I think that's really
interesting and certainly their
technology was like hyper Advanced
compared to anything that we have
so it's revealed that the Elder things
are responsible for the creation of life
on Earth
how did that happen why did they create
life on Earth
well initially they created things like
the Chagas for their own purposes to
serve whatever purpose they need like a
shagath it seems like it's almost
something that can be kind of programmed
to produce whatever they want and as a
biological byproduct of the shaggas all
life on Earth was eventually formed and
this is implied to be completely
accidental and this occurs long after
the Elder things disappear I mean like
the the biological material over
billions of years is implied to become
us eventually so the Shabbos of the
biological parent of all Life by
accident you know like so I think that's
the ultimate that's the ultimate like
kind of terrifying thing because humans
we're always asking ourselves where did
we come from what's the meaning of our
existence and in this story Lovecraft is
saying there is no meaning of our
existence we're literally a biological
accident and yeah that's kind of
depressing but just really really makes
for a great right you know turn in a
story I think so you mentioned shagats
can you explain what those are so Chagas
are like these big bubbling masses of
goo and initially they were created to
be the slave class of the Elder things
they just did whatever the slave
whatever the older things wanted I think
they could produce certain biological
material that was that the Elder things
needed they just did whatever they were
commanded to do by the Elder things but
eventually there was some kind of revolt
and the shockets gained their own
independence and the race of the Elder
things fell and they presumably fled
back to wherever they came from though
as we see in the book some of them did
get left behind and some of them were in
fact preserved in the ice for billions
of years perhaps so the Elder things
left this city where did they go that's
a good question so where did they go and
then also like how to why did they go so
it implies that like I guess there was a
rebellion of the Chagas maybe whatever
they were doing
maybe it all just became like too
hostile maybe they lost the war against
Cthulhu and his pre-human spawn because
we do learn from cthulh that Cthulhu is
still here waiting to regain his
dominion over the years so it implies
that the Elder things lost so I imagined
that after they lost perhaps some of
them stayed in their city for a while
but obviously there was this rebellion
and eventually maybe it all just got too
chaotic to maintain and they went back
into I don't know the outer dimensions
of the macroverse returned to whatever
Realms of existence they initially came
from
um so that that seems I guess the most
likely place where they would have went
I think so at the end of the book The
Character Danforth the student the
student he sees something out the window
of the plane and it makes him go mad
what what is it that he sees
so this is something that's left kind of
open for interpretation now
it does mention
when they were looking at the
hieroglyphs that there was some unnamed
evil at the center of an even greater
mountain range just beyond the mountains
of Madness
like some unspeakable unnamed evil and
I've always thought
ever since I read this that that is what
Danforth saw I did a short video essay
on at the mountains of Madness years ago
and in that video that is also what I
speculated that he looked back at this
unnamed place of evil he looked into
whatever it was and it made him mad now
we talked about
the idea that the Elder things traveled
through like kind of an opening in outer
space in Francois behringer's version of
at the mountains of Madness which I
highly recommend it's fully Illustrated
he depicts that scene as Danforth
looking back you see and you see like
this kind of almost this Distortion of
outer space and it looks like almost
like another
place that's like a portal a portal yeah
right and you see it kind of like this
tentacle monster and I I I I it gave me
the impression that if Danforth looked
into that place
of course that would have ripped his
mind apart it kind of reminds me of
Stephen King's it now it is if you don't
know like Stephen King's take on a
lovecraftian horror in my opinion
um and in that book The Creature it can
sometimes show people its dead lights
and all the dead lights are are the
Gateway into where it came from the
macro first right and just by someone of
of a simple mind like a human glimpsing
that Maca verse and being forced to
experience the chaos and and just like
the macroscopic nature of it and just
the complexity of it all and the
contradictions of it all it it breaks
them and it breaks the mind so then
forth looked into the Indescribable the
unthinkable and the unknowable and after
looking in he couldn't let go the abyss
stared right back into him and that's
essentially what happens to Danforth in
my opinion and that's kind of a common
Trope in lovecraft's work it happens
often
once someone becomes privy to these
unseen things once someone becomes privy
to the Unseen World
um it leaves a Mark
um it's almost like a disease that
infects until it consumes completely
it's terrifying it's almost like it's
the Infectious power of knowledge
um you know people say ignorance is
bliss I think lovecraft's work kind of
it simplifies that it's it's kind of the
height of that you don't want to know
kind of energy you'd be better off not
knowing the truth kind of energy so the
whole point of this story the narrator
is trying to warn people against going
back to Antarctica and he wants to keep
this a secret
why would he want to keep this a secret
the one I think he doesn't want people
like exploring Antarctica and unleashing
something you know what I mean
um because if if more people go there
and more explore there's a chance that
you know the shot gets to get out I mean
that the Elder things like get out and
come after us or something like that and
also I think it goes back to that idea
that maybe we're just better off not
knowing where we came from maybe the
truth of where we came from is just too
terrible so that's the essential idea
there are terrible things lurking that
we don't want to unleash and maybe it's
just better not to know so I think
that's where Danforth is that's where
dire is coming from because he's looking
at what happened to Danforth like he
doesn't want the fate of danfor to you
know be transferred to like all of
humanity and something is still there
there are things still there so us going
there and just like moving things around
and peeking around maybe there's darker
things that might take notice like the
unnamed evil at that more distant
mountain range what is that thing he
can't keep it secret forever he's trying
he's only he's delaying the inevitable
really but yeah I get where he's coming
from so what I like about at the
mountains of Madness is that it kind of
evokes this sense of exploration and
Discovery that's kind of less possible
in the modern era it kind of like makes
me think of like back in the day when
like I don't know maybe archaeologists
were discovering like all these species
of dinosaurs for the first time and the
sense of like ah and wonder that that
must have evoked how crazy would it have
been to learn about dinosaurs and not
knowing anything about dinosaurs that
must have blown people's minds it must
have been insane yeah it's yeah and it
kind of I've I've thought about this
like my whole life basically it's like
we live in the world of like technology
and satellites where we can like scan
the entire globe
and we have all this information and
history we have all this access to
history and information but back in the
time when Lovecraft was writing the
story there was still like this sense
about the world there was a sense of
mystery about the world we hadn't
Unearthed every corner of the world at
this point in time and so that's like
that's a great Avenue for Lovecraft to
venture into to to to kind of like
explore these ideas right so like we
talked about in the last episode about
how space was one of the great Primal
Mysteries and also the ocean was one of
the great Primal Mysteries one of the
great Primal gateways because they're
both like kind of like in accessible to
us but they're there and they're so
prominent the past is kind of like that
as well the past is like a vast ocean of
mystery and Lovecraft in this story and
through a lot of his stories is able to
fill that with so many like Horrors and
fears and Terrible Things
um and I think that probably like
digging up dinosaurs for the first time
probably evoked that same sense of in
people like there is this like
there were other rulers of the world
there is an ancient world before our
world that doesn't exist anymore so yeah
I I get yeah so that's really really a
cool way to think about it I think do
you think they'll ever make an
adaptation of at the mountains of
Madness I sure hope so
um honestly Guillermo del Toro's version
I hope I still hold out hope for that
that comes out one day
and obviously that didn't get made
because Ridley Scott was making
Prometheus at the time and I think him
and Guillermo are friends and I think
you almost thought that at the mountains
of Madness would be too similar to
Prometheus so at the mountains of
Madness didn't get made but Prometheus
is kind of like a a pseudo adaptation in
in a few ways it's got some similarities
but it's not like a direct adaptation or
anything like that well let's change
gears to Prometheus
why don't you give us a summary of what
Prometheus is about
so Prometheus takes place in the same
universe as the alien movies
um and it's kind of like a semi prequel
to alien but essentially
scientists realize that
in all these different places on Earth
there are these cave paintings and
drawings from ancient Humanity early
Humanity pointing to one particular
planet in one particular star system
and they go on this huge vessel called
the Prometheus funded by Weyland Corp of
alien Fame
and they go to the planet which is
called
lv223 and the planet is called this for
a very specific reason it is a direct
reference to Leviticus 22 3.
say to them for the generations to come
if any of your descendants is
ceremonially unclean and yet comes near
the sacred offerings that the Israelites
consecrate to the Lord that person must
be cut off from my presence I am the
Lord
so the planet's name directly references
that quote for very specific reason
which we'll get to in a little bit so
essentially they get to this planet
um the what they think initially might
be the home world of the engineers but
they eventually uncover that it is in
fact not the home world of the engineers
on this planet they uncover various
things they they notice that some
catastrophe has occurred something
happened to the engineers on this planet
um and they slowly uncover the Mysteries
and they and as they're exploring the
planet and the structure on the planet
things start to go wrong for them so
that is just a basic synopsis without
giving away too much initially so then
what are the main themes of the movie
well I think the main themes of
Prometheus include things like hubris
not only human hubris but also the
hubris of the engineers which is kind of
explored as well the engineers were
creating biological weapons and it got
out of hand in the same way that humans
sometimes produce technology that gets
out of hand and it kind of bites us the
engineers met the ultimate fate at the
hands of their own technology it's also
about greed you know the greed of the
Weyland Corp
um it's about the origin of life on
Earth it's about God versus man and who
is God and who is Mortal it's about
Consciousness and you know biological
life versus artificial life and which
one is Superior or or inferior to the
other
um you know it explores that idea with
the character David
um so yeah I think those are the main
themes of Prometheus
so why is the movie called Prometheus
and who is Prometheus so the movie is
called Prometheus in a direct reference
to the Greek myth of Prometheus who
stole fire from the gods and brought it
to Mankind and for this he was punished
now this story has been retold in
various different places various
different myths throughout human history
another example of the same story is the
Garden of Eden
um the forbidden fruit represents the
knowledge of God
um and for partaking in the forbidden
fruit mankind is punished
um and in Prometheus reflects these
ideas as well they are going to this
planet to consume the knowledge of the
Gods to learn where they came from and
for this they are punished as well so I
think that is essentially why the movie
is called Prometheus it is kind of the
desire to know that burns Us in the end
at the beginning of the movie an
engineer is on earth a long time ago and
he sacrifices himself and presumably
creates life on Earth
did he create all life on Earth or do
you think he just infected proto-humans
to guide their evolution along
so I guess it's up for interpretation we
do see like some Greenery some algae so
we know that Earth isn't totally devoid
of life but it could potentially be
devoid of animal life
so
if I had to lean in One Direction and I
don't know either way I would say that
they seeded all life on Earth
potentially in the same way that you
know in HP lovecraft's Story the shot
that's seed all life on Earth so what do
you think their initial plan with Earth
was I think it was probably a scientific
experiment although that opening scene
there does seem to be kind of something
religious about it there's a ritualistic
nature in the way that scene
um plays like the engineer walks out in
a robe and he takes it off and he has
um this goo and kind of the ceremonial
like jar almost a ceremonial container
um so it's almost like a religious thing
that's occurring here so perhaps they
were a particular religious sect of the
engineer race or perhaps they were on or
perhaps it was
um specifically just like a scientific
experiment that they later decided to
terminate but either way they did
eventually decide to terminate the whole
project why did this happen
um so that is to be the more interesting
question why did they decide to
terminate and why do they decide to come
back and kill Humanity even though of
course they didn't get to that point but
they made the decision so it does
mention at some point in the movie
that this the point in which they
decided to terminate was about 2 000
years ago now that aligns pretty clearly
with the death of Jesus right so we can
assume that the engineers started life
on Earth through sacrificing themselves
they visited and guided Humanity in the
form of various gods and Jesus was their
last appearance they must have not liked
our reaction to him either they got
pissed off at how we killed him or that
after his death we went right back to
fighting Wars perhaps because those wars
were fought in his name well I think
it's I think it has something to do with
the fact that we killed him you know I
mean they send they potentially sinned
or Inspire this man
um and then we like totally reject the
wisdom that they're trying to give us
and because of that they're like okay
we've tried multiple times with this
experiment of ours but it has gone sour
and now it's time to terminate and I
think the idea of them
um being either themselves religious
leaders or like inspiring and influence
the religious leaders ties ties
into the theory that the whole thing
from the beginning was a religious thing
that was occurring as well you know
because I can't imagine that everybody
on the engineer planet or the engineer
what I think is probably like an
engineer like Interstellar system I feel
like they probably inhabit more than one
planet I can't imagine that all of them
want the same thing all of the engineers
that exist aren't involved with the
Earth Project you know what I mean not
this is a specific group of them and if
you're going to do something like this
seating a whole planet probably have a
motivation for doing it and for big
things like this oftentimes that
motivation is is is religious in nature
like they're they're doing something
that's greater than themselves so I
could totally see it being a religious
thing and I can totally see them trying
to see if they could lead a race of
people down a specific path
failing at that and deciding that it
wasn't worth it
so what do you think the black goo is it
seems like a biological weapon that
breaks down DNA and reforms it but it
seems to have a different function
depending on who uses it because when
the engineer drinks it in the beginning
of the movie it breaks down his body and
creates life on Earth but when the
humans consume it it turns them into a
monster
well I think
it's technology that we don't understand
right I I feel like the black goo is
some form of biological technology that
can be programmed with whatever purpose
the engineers needed to do
you know what I'm saying it's kind of
like the Chagas in at the mountains of
Madness the chocolates could kind of be
biologically programmed to do whatever
they needed them to do so it's it's it's
biological technology and the way it
actually operates is a little bit
obscure but that's what I think it is
it's kind of like a canvas for like
whatever and perhaps maybe when it
doesn't have a specific instructions it
behaves in random ways that are kind of
unpredictable or something like that and
then also we know that the substance had
to be volatile itself because it's
ultimately what destroys the engineer
based on that particular planet
I think that it might be something that
they found and that they were
experimenting with not something that
they invented because the black goo
reminds me of the life seed from
mountains of Madness and who created the
creators perhaps this is where
everything comes from and this is their
God that's really interesting and it
kind of makes sense if they found it
that they would be like
this particular religious sect of the
definitely religious they seem spiritual
it's almost like they are worshiping the
black goo they have them in fancy
canisters lined up in a hall with
monuments yeah exactly exactly there is
a spiritual aspect to this so maybe it
is something that they found and maybe
it is something that they have been
experimenting with it's interesting but
I tend to think personally
that the engineers might just be a
naturally forming race of beings that
just got to a sufficient level of
advancement where some of them went out
and decided to create more life
potentially and that doesn't mean that
they didn't like find the quote-unquote
life C let's just call it the live seed
black goo doesn't mean that they didn't
actually find that somewhere but I do I
do see this as like I feel like they
progress probably naturally I don't
think they necessarily need a Creator
because I was thinking of the panspermia
hypothesis which suggests that life or
the building blocks of life originated
beyond our planet and was spread
throughout the Universe through comets
meteors and other celestial bodies so
perhaps all life is the product of the
black goo like that like that like black
that black goo and its fundamental
Essence is the seed of all life in the
universe yeah that's really interesting
and I didn't even think about that that
kind of like ties it all together
because we know from Prometheus that the
engineers and humans we literally have
their DNA
so maybe that's something that maybe
that's what the black goo does it's it
it's an assimilator of DNA and it's a
changer of DNA and it's something that
passes on DNA it's like the Catalyst for
Life yeah well I wonder like that's
interesting because I wonder if in the
alien Universe now in the Prometheus
Universe if we
uncovered another species of sentient
beings and we tested their DNA would it
be like oh they are also related to the
engineers you know what I mean because
that that would mean that the live seed
has been passed on from species to
species to species to species and it's
kind of something that's maybe like
terrible if it's like not used right but
it can also be something that's very
effective and beautiful because it
brings life so we've been mentioning
creators and gods and stuff like that
and one of the big questions that I
asked myself while I watch Prometheus is
why does the character David exist the
Android and I think he exists for a very
very clear reason you notice in the
scene where he encounters the engineer
he says something like hmm he's mortal
or something like that because okay so
the humans are there to find their God
to meet their own God their creator
David's already met his creator and been
just utterly disappointed by us we have
disappointed David So in in in in in in
in some way I think he was disappointed
to see that the engineer wasn't this
Supreme Being because he sees himself as
better than his creator and he like is
he's essentially Immortal he's a lot
smarter than his creator so I guess
David was hoping that like he was gonna
find like in a way like almost like his
grandfather God in in in in I think in
some in some way so I think David is
there
to bring up the question
does it really matter if you meet your
Creator and really should you meet your
creator because if you do you're
probably just going to be disappointed
and that's the same that's honestly
what's interesting about it is that's
what happens to Weyland at the end as
he's dying his final words are there's
nothing he meets his creator and like
David ultimately he's disappointed he
comes to the edge of the universe to
meet his creator and he's ultimately
disappointed so it's like is it even
worth it so I just find David to be a
very very fascinating character and I
really like the way this character is
handled in Prometheus because we see
very clearly that he is sentient that he
is conscious that he is absolutely aware
um so I feel like that gives a lot of
weight to like his interactions with the
people around him and the things that he
does
so David is portrayed as a villain but
do you think that he is evil in any sort
of way evil no I think he's he's deeply
curious and he's not really that
concerned about humans that much because
he does I think ultimately feel Superior
and I think for most of the movie he's
just taking Waylon's orders his father's
orders
but if we're talking about alien
Covenant which is the sequel to this
that I don't very much like because it
doesn't answer any of the questions that
it promises to answer alien Covenant I
definitely do think he takes a turn to
being evil but that's a whole different
discussion and that's not this version
of David in my opinion so evil
I don't think he's evil no
why do you think the engineer kills
Weyland and attempts to kill David
towards the end of the movie okay well
in a deleted scene from Prometheus it
totally gives you the reason why and
basically Weyland basically begs the
engineer for eternal life he says I he
basically says that he deserves life and
that he deserves to live and of course
this offends the engineer this goes back
to the Bible quote that we mentioned
earlier so Leviticus 22 3 I'm gonna read
it one more time
say to them for the generations to come
if any of your descendants is
ceremonially unclean and yet comes near
the sacred offerings that the Israelites
consecrate to the Lord that person must
be cut off from my presence I am the
Lord so Waylon is coming to the engineer
with these demands and and this hubris
thinking that he deserves eternal life
for whatever reason and the engineers
just like look at this disgusting thing
that we created I I I can imagine that
the engineer is just reminded of the
reason that they wanted to destroy us in
the first place they're like can you
believe these these rats that we made
that we were going to exterminate are
now coming demanding things of us yeah
so he had to be snuffed out and I feel
like that is the exact reason that
Wayland is killed he's punished for his
hubris essentially and of course David
was just the messenger so you know so he
had to go to you don't think the
engineer saw David as his Creations
creation and that had something to do
with it I don't think the engineer had
any particular like malice towards David
he probably like recognized him and
recognized what he was
and perhaps he was like ah it's a
curiosity but I think that scene is
mainly was out of anger towards Weyland
because he kind of like doesn't he
snatch David's head off and hit Wayland
with it so like Waylon's creation
becomes the instrument of his own death
so it's kind of like this weird irony
um but yeah I don't think that was done
out of malice or hard feelings towards
Dave David himself
I think I think if anything the engineer
is like ha curiosity a mechanical man
like ah what is this he's like a tool
you know well I think David represents
the culmination of knowledge that humans
have Acquired and it goes back to the
title of the film Prometheus we have
this God that is mad that humans have
also gained the ability to create life
yeah yeah and and then also to come to
the Stars seeking them out and he's kind
of like yeah like you you will be
punished for this knowledge that you
have acquired you will now be punished
for it yeah it totally goes back to the
title absolutely so at the end of this
movie we are given no answers well some
answers but more questions and it
implies that these questions will be
answered in the next film as we all know
that does not happen which is why we
actually chose to Omit alien Covenant
from this discussion it's more fun to
contemplate this film not knowing all
the the answers kind of like how
mountains of Madness is more terrifying
when you don't truly understand the
nature of the Elder things
but do you think we will ever get
answers to this movie
well I think Ridley Scott really wanted
to to do a space Jesus movie that was
his original idea and he just kind of
got roped into doing an Alien prequel I
recommend to everybody on the internet
to check out comic book girl 19's
Prometheus video she's got two of them
out there and they're absolutely great
they go into detail about the production
of the movie and some behind the scenes
things and I I really think they're
really great to understanding these
movies so I think that really Scott
wanted to do that he wanted to explore
those specific ideas but kind of got
shoehorned into doing an alien movie so
I think that if he could maybe he would
and I would love to see uh an actual
exploration on the engineers and their
actual motivations I would love to see
that so the question is I don't know
maybe maybe well he is making a third
film in this Trilogy it comes out next
year and I didn't know that alien
Romulus I think it's called alien
Romulus so interesting title but put
alien in the name so it makes me think
it'll just be an alien movie that has
nothing to do with the engineers that's
the red flag and that was kind of the
problem with with obviously alien
coveted is that it doesn't satisfyingly
answer any of those questions and it
just gives you like the the standard
alien xenomorph type stuff and you know
that's fun but it's not like what we
wanted from Prometheus actually so I'm
hoping that maybe the third one I'm
definitely gonna go see it where big
Ridley Scott fans so we're gonna see it
so yeah so let's talk about the
similarities between Prometheus and at
the mountains of Madness all right so
there's there's a lot so um the big one
is that Earth was seated with life so in
at the mountains of Madness You've Got
The Accidental seeding of Life by the
Elder things via the shagats and then
Prometheus you've got the engineers
seeding life intentionally the
intentions of the creators are kind of
reversed in these stories in mountains
of Madness the Elder things accidentally
create human life while constructing the
shagafs while in Prometheus they
intentionally create humans but
accidentally create shagaths or
Xenomorphs I guess you could say that
but I don't know if it was
accidental or if like that was going to
be the method by which they destroyed
Humanity you know what I mean was
Humanity just gonna have like a race of
Xenomorphs taking it over I don't know I
don't it's it's like I said it's it's
pretty vague I guess but that go but
that does go back to another similarity
between Prometheus and at the mountains
of Madness because we have this Advanced
race of beings like the Elder things
that have a creation that goes wrong we
know that the Shag gets Rebel and gain
their independence and we know that
something very very very bad happened to
the engineers on
um that planet where they were
bioengineering this black goo or
whatever
um so they were sufficiently Advanced
but their technology ultimately turns on
them and kind of like screws them over
significantly so that's a major
similarity
and then obviously we've got the X the
expedition to the unknown place so I
think Lovecraft perhaps
couldn't he wasn't he didn't have the
idea of space exploration on his mind
you know that wasn't something that he
was really thinking about so like the
most remote place that he could come up
with was Antarctica but really the
planet lv223 is just another version of
Antarctica but it's a modern version of
Antarctica because like I said
we we've satellite scanned every part of
the planet but space is the final
frontier so I think the expedition to
like this distant place this realm of
mysteries is is is a very very very key
similarity and then of course the fact
that in these places they discover these
ancient structures and like weird like
hieroglyphics and and weird art stuff
and they discover all this evidence of
like this ancient race that was very
technologically advanced
um so yeah the similarities go on and on
and on and on basically and of course we
talked about like the life seed and the
black goo
um the genetic bioengineering that both
races of ancient beings engaged in
um both stories kind of have the theme
of you know the acquiring of knowledge
um being also met with punishment
because like we mentioned the fact that
Danforth looks back and he sees but he's
punished for seeing so this the
similarities between the mountains of
Madness and Prometheus are pretty
expansive and they go deeper than most
people think I think a lot of people
um I think you could read at the
mountains of Madness and watch
Prometheus and maybe not see all the
similarities if you're not really
thinking about it but once you catch on
to them you can very very clearly see
um how Prometheus is definitely inspired
by at the mountains of Madness to some
degree
so do you believe an ancient astronaut
theory well believe is a strong word I
think it's I think it's an interesting
idea and I don't discount anything so
I'm willing to believe in and if the
evidence shows itself but I think it's a
cool idea so ancient astronaut theory is
of course the idea that the Earth was
visited by aliens in our past and that
these beings
um helped us out with you know maybe
like the pyramids or helping us acquire
certain knowledge um teaching us
agriculture like helping form us into a
civilization essentially
um and usually this idea is accompanied
with like the concept of perhaps that
there was a sufficiently advanced human
civilization on Earth and that we'd lost
a lot of that technology and information
but yeah that's essentially ancient
astronaut theory I'm sure a lot of
people are familiar with Ancient Aliens
and how kind of it gets a little out
there but you know I think there's some
cool things in that pile of weird things
so how about you do you believe in
ancient astronaut theory no
no I do not it's fun to think about I've
read Chariots of the Gods and looked
into some of Graham Hancock's work but
the more I look into it the more I roll
my eyes at it yeah I mean honestly it
seems like Graham Hancock might have
been reading a little bit of at the
mountains of Madness because there's a
lot of like correlations and
similarities between like did you just
read at the mountains of Madness and
then just make this a little bit because
he does say that the ancient
civilization once lived in Antarctica I
think yeah yeah
well what other works do you know of
that have been inspired by at the
mountains of Madness well a major one is
the thing I think that's a great example
of one that's been inspired by at the
mountains of Madness of course it's
different but it takes place in
Antarctica and you've got you know
you're digging up like a Monster out of
ice
um you've got you've got a lot of the
qualities of at the mountains of Madness
in that story and the thing is
absolutely a fantastic movie and we are
moving into autumn uh in in the United
States it's fall time so it's like
Halloween time around here and I think
the thing is a perfect perfect Halloween
movie to watch and I think it's a great
one and it's definitely inspired by the
mountains of Madness you got the
scientific Expedition the team and the
Monstrous things occurring and yeah I
really like it a lot have you seen the
new one do you like it I have seen the
new thing the new thing is actually a
prequel to the original one and um it
basically just like kind of fills in the
gaps I don't think it's really necessary
but if like if you've seen the thing and
you love it and you just like kind of
want to know what happened like right
before that then because there's a lot
of mysteries in the original the thing
we know that
the thing originally was dug up by a
different team of of explorers and
scientists and basically the prequel is
the story of the people that originally
dug it up and you know I enjoyed it for
what it was
um you know the original is obviously
Superior
I got one it's been a while since I've
seen it but it's a sci-fi movie called
Mission to Mars and I'm pretty sure when
they go to Mars they find structures
built by an ancient race and it heavily
implies that there was once a
civilization on Mars that seeded Earth
with life
but I have not seen it for a while so I
don't know if I can recommend it as a
good movie but I remember finding it a
lot of fun when I was a teenager
I just think that idea is just brilliant
because it really just like checks human
narcissism like how we think that we've
dominated the planet and how like there
is nothing greater than us that has come
before so like lovecraft's introduces
this idea of like no we're actually
nothing compared to what has existed in
the past and we actually could never
even comprehend how powerful they were
so I just think that's just just a
fantastic concept to play in as a
storyteller
[Music]
so at the mountains of Madness is a
great science fiction Horror Story and
for me these is a pretty decent movie
though it has its problems I still
really love it
um and it's been really fun doing this
podcast and talking about two of our
favorite things so thanks so much for
listening guys as I said in the
beginning you can find us wherever you
find your podcast Apple podcast Google
podcast and Spotify don't forget to also
subscribe to our YouTube channel we will
be posting episodes every other Friday
thanks for listening guys
foreign
[Music]